Офіційна зарплата президента України
28 тисяч гривень
в перерахунку 840 євро
Його німецький колега заробляє майже 19 тисяч євро
тобто в 22 рази більше
Правда, президент Порошенко живе
не на зарплату
адже щоразу її жертвує
Український прем’єр-міністр має
оклад у 20 тисяч гривень
тобто 600 євро
З надбавками Володимир Гройсман отримав у січні
30,5 тисячі гривень, тобто 900 євро
Канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель заробляє в місяць
дещо більше 18 тисяч євро
Оклад генпрокурора України більший за оклади президента та прем’єра
37 тисяч гривень
Утім, з надбавками Юрій Луценко заробив
у січні 325 тисяч гривень
тобто майже 10 тисяч євро
Це майже зарплата німецького генпрокурора
який має оклад близько 11 тисяч євро
Тим часом середня зарплата українців
у 2017 році склала 7,5 тиcячі гривень
у перерахунку 225 євро
А це середній дохід у ФРН у 2016 році
1840 євро
Зарплата високопосадовців ФРН
перевищує середню
щонайбільше у 10 разів
Посадовий оклад генпрокурора України
перевищує середню зарплату лише в 5 разів
Але реальний офіційний заробіток за січень
більший майже у 45 разів